we oh man what's up bout wheelman and
there's 286 f-bombs in wheelman and I
thought the Scarface we looked into it
Scarface which I thought had the most
f-bombs only has 226 so we have more
there's only one other film and I don't
I forgot the name of it some obscure
film that has more
oh yeah it's called that's a classic
good news a classic movie good family
movie yeah she knew Stuart never did
this is a great you this is such a great
idea for a movie and it's a challenge
cuz you're you you play a getaway driver
but getaway driver who's basically that
90 percent of the film ninety-eight
percent of the film takes place in one
of two cars and you know I often say you
know I'm not George Clooney like I'm not
a giant movie store people go oh let's
go watch George Clooney in a car like
this is a risk right so you know my
partner and I joe carnahan we made the
movie for five-and-a-half million bucks
with netflix in 19 days we did it at
night and we were scared out of our
pants doing it but it seems to have
worked I mean it's a yes when you watch
it it's it's a lot of fun for 86 minutes
you